hello everyone and welcome to a brutal
attacking game from the Hungarian rapid
Championship 2023 it's a game from the
penultimate around the Peters filler
versus Amin tabatabai uh maybe it's not
the penultimate round uh maybe it's a
round before then let me just check I
don't want to trick you guys yeah this
uh yeah 13 Rounds was played yeah this
is uh around 12. so definitely the
penultimate round and swiddler only lost
one game so far and he's in contention
for first place he lost the one game to
Magnus Crossings Nemesis uh San
Francisco and I'm in tabatabai is
without a single law so uh you know a
lot is on the line here and it's a
brilliant attacking game a lot of
sacrifices happening you guys will enjoy
it let's check it out and then we're
going to discuss the standings and what
what happened 297 players participating
in this tournament and well uh we're
gonna say more after we check out the
game so Spiller opens with Pawn to see
for a few uh videos ago I mentioned that
it's a wonderful way for you to avoid
all of the tricky lines that come from
from let's say playing E4 or D for here
you just avoid all of this and you play
uh some some good chess with Pawn 36
going for the Asian core defense G3 and
now Pawn to D5 with Bishop to G2 and
Knight to F6 we have Knight to F3 bishop
t7 and now both players Castle so
castles castles and pawn to B3 uh
similar slow playing this he wants the
fianca to both of his Bishops we have
Pawn to D4 grabbing more space in the
center as Sevilla did allow it and
usually here you will see Ponte 3 or
Bishop to B2 but here we have Knight the
E5 and knights the E5 is perhaps not the
absolute best way to go about this
position would wide but it's an
excellent way of trying to take
advantage of a Rapids time format maybe
your opponent doesn't know this line and
he will simply trust you the reason why
it's not uh maybe that impressive is
that uh Bishop to D6 really forces the
Knight to move uh there's really not
much you can do other than to move the
Knight because if you play before you
can just trade characters captures and
go on ig4 and you're going to win that
E5 Pawn yes you won the bishop fair but
it's it's not like it's gonna do all
that much but obviously yeah something
in mind uh but the best would be to
Simply challenge that right away it's a
hard decision to make because you
already made a move with the bishop and
then you don't want to waste another
Temple playing Bishop to D6 so Pawn to
C5 was played and now comes spawn to E3
we have Queen to C7 now only Now Pawn to
F4 Knight B to D7 and now e captures on
D4 we are C characters and now Knights
to D3 not allowing the trade to happen
on E5 Knight to C5 challenging the
Knight Here and Now Queen to E2 we have
captures captures and pawn to E5 now
challenging the E5 Pawn uh F captures on
E5 and now Knight to G4 going after the
E5 pawn bishop to A3 now offering to
trade of the dark Square Bishops and now
Knight captures on E5 simply attacking
the queen on D3 uh we have Queen
captures on the 4 and now Rook the d8 so
I mean definitely getting some
development moves in as Fiddler's Queen
is under attack Queen to F4 now the
Knight cannot move as the queen on C7
would hang so Bishop to F6 we have
Knight to C3 and now Queen to A5 uh
putting pressure on the bishop here and
here's Villar finds a most spectacular
move one that uh not easily
uh spotted he plays Knight the E4 and
what's the idea here it doesn't seem
like uh you have compensation for just
giving up the bishop on A3 uh but you
have to capture it if you don't capture
the bishop black is just dead lost uh to
give you an example if you play
something like let's say queen B6 check
and you want to guard the bishop on F6
uh Bishop to C5 happens and now after
the queen moves you can just trade
captures captures captures and captures
and now look at this spawn to D4 okay
the Knight attacks the bishop you'll
simply move the bishop you'll attack The
Rook okay Rook capture Sun D4 now comes
Bishop characters on F6 again attacks
The Rook Rook the D6 attacks the bishop
Now Pawn to C5 and there's really no
good way to play this with black uh
you're gonna suffer for the rest of the
game there's no good way to develop here
and especially if you capture dangerous
Bishop D7 and you lose material as
there's no way to actually defend at
night due to the bishop pair so after
Knight E4 the best move here of course
for Amin is to capture the bishop he
played the queen captures on A3 grabbing
the bishop now look at svidler's idea
Knight captures an F6 with check G
captures and pawn to D4 okay nice to G6
Queen captures and F6 he grabs another
Pawn threatens the F7 Pawn but now just
Queen to E7 and where is the
compensation for the sacrifice piece
well Queen to F2 we have Fawn to F5 and
now Pawn to C5 you're probably expecting
Pawn to D5 but filler actually goes Pawn
to C5 first with Bishop to E6 now
countering the D5 Square not allowing
Pawn to D5 and now Rook 8 to E1 now this
is again a threat as the queen is on the
same file as The Rook Queen to F7 and
now Bishop captures on B7 as the bishop
on E6 will fall as well so okay Queen
capture some B7 Rook captures on E6 and
now Rook to D5 just stopping those pawns
not allowing them to move any further
Rook the F6 by Peter we have Pawn the F4
trying to open up the white King's
position uh Queen to E2 and now how do
you defend this rookie 38 was played
Queen the E6 with check King to G7 and
now Rook 1 captures on F4 we have Knight
captures on F4 so Peter also sacrifices
The Exchange here Rook captures and now
Pawn to H5 so now swindler is down a
full rook and how can he how can he play
this well uh good thing for him is that
objectively it's a draw but the bad
thing for Amin is that if he doesn't
play Perfect moves then swindler is just
gonna win this so Queen to F6 check was
played and now as uh things usually work
in chess uh King to G8 is a draw King to
H7 is a loss for amitaba tabai and he
played King to H7 but now you guys have
to figure out why it's a draw it's not
easy to spot remember you are down a
full Rook so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Peter while I
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
wonderful idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
the E4 this is the movie you have to
find and now the threat is Rook the E7
with check and there is no good way to
defend this whatever you play Rook D7
will just uh you know kick the queen out
of the game and then you're just gonna
Checkmate the black king so the only way
to defend this is to actually prevent
Rook D7 but that also means you are
allowing this beautiful Fork because the
defend you have to put to either Rook on
D7 and then C6 will just forgot the
queen and either Rook so Rook 5 to D7
was played and now of course spawn to C6
it's not required you could actually
play Pont uh Rook to E5 and just win the
game on the spot but it's rapid Thriller
played Pawn to C6 and now he just has a
completely winning game Rook the F7 was
played Queen capture 78 other moves
aren't uh any better with Queen captures
and C6 and I'll just Queen to E8 he is
up three pawns and of course completely
winning now it's just time to figure out
how to uh take advantage of the position
uh you know the most properly we have
Queen the E6 offering a queen trade and
now Rook to F6 preventing this with
Queen to D5 and Rook to F7 with King G2
Ponte A6 and now Pawn to B4 preparing to
create another pass Pawn as you already
have one uh Rook to F6 and now Pawn to
A4 we have King H6 and now Queen to E5
making room for the past d-pawn to start
marching forward as well King the H7 and
now Pawn to B5 with a captures on B5 a
captures and Rook to F5 but uh doesn't
really matter all that much you are down
three pawns Queen to C7 with check King
to H6 and now Queen to d8 we have King
back to H7 now comes Pawn to B6 the pawn
is nicely defended so we don't have to
worry Rook def do with check trading
Rooks captures captures and now Queen to
F6
uh just the cutting off the the black
king and also defending the D4 Pawn
defending the B6 pawn and also uh
defending the white king along the f
file a few more checks will be given
before we see an actual resignation
because that's just how it just works
queen king day three Queen the C1 check
King T4 and now Queen to B1 with check
King to E5 and now Queen to B5 with
check we have King to F4 Queen to B2 now
going after the pawn here but just uh
sorry about this Pawn here uh but just
King to G5 now preparing to Checkmate
the black king Ponte H4 and now Queen F7
check with King David and queen G6 King
G6 now threatening Checkmate here uh
Queen to B1 check and now Queen to F5
and it was in this position and move 58
that I'm in tabatabai resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you can't do anything you're getting
checkmated on the next move Queen to f8
will be Checkmate or you can do
something like Queen H5 checkfall by
Queen H7 check followed by Queen to F7
Checkmate and if you capture the pawn
here yes this does come come with check
but then you play Queen to F6 a counter
check and the blocking uh the The
Queen's check to the white king black
will have to trade and then of course
you just Advance this Pawn to Victory of
course completely winning position uh so
yeah absolutely brilliant stuff by
swindler like I said out of the 13 games
that he played in this tournament in the
Hungarian rapid Championship he only
lost the Sun and silgirob uh but uh not
none of the other games so uh very
nicely done by him and he finishes one
full point ahead of the field uh he wins
with 11 out of 13 and some three players
were on 10 out of 13.00 and Alexander
were trailing him and then a bunch of
other people with nine and a half points
including uh who really had a beautiful
start I think he started with like six
wins and then he lost his first game to
uh Tabata by or maybe that was a
different tournament I'm gonna check I
don't want to trick you guys let me just
quickly check yeah Prague got seventh
place uh
uh yeah no he he drew his game to
swedler and Drew also his game to have
been done but to buy so he only lost uh
yeah he only lost to maxulu and Simon
sugero obviously both of them had really
an exceptional tournament so of course
um the results just followed uh but yeah
absolutely incredible Peter swiddler uh
comes out to play a tournament out of
297 players uh he clinches first place a
full point ahead of everyone else
absolutely spectacular uh I mean he is a
class above uh above everyone else here
and he showed it once again uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
really a brutal attacking game very
nicely done by Peter I would like to
thank bullet just thriller.com
Rod Hill for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the curvature of everything
else that's happening in the Chess World
and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do use
that hashtag suggestion to suggest some
games see you soon